- Please welcome former
American Idol artist Casey
and former artist from
The Voice Meagan McNeal.
(crowd applauds, cheers)
I love this.
It's like blending my two worlds.
I love it; I'm so excited
to have you both on.
But each of you is doing something unique,
so Meagan we'll start with you.
You were on The Voice like
right before I started,
- Yeah.
- right?
- Yep. I was like,
- I just missed you.
- Season 13.
- Oh, that's the number today.
- That's the number.
- Yeah.
- So, I think that's the
season that Chloe Kohanski won.
And I'm from Chicago,
and so I landed on Jennifer Hudson's team,
which was like
- Yes, I love her.
I've always respected her.
All right, well, we have a
video actually of Meagan singing
on Chicago's L train
recently that went viral.
Take a look.
♪ I heard you say. ♪
(upbeat trumpet music)
- Such a mama rocking that baby, what?
I'm like, I mean, as a mom
who has rocked a baby before
because like I never looked that cool.
Like you have your baby
wrapped up while you're like
hitting those notes.
That's some big notes
on a train, especially.
- You know we, I was like
I, out of all the singing
that I've been doing, you know,
this video of us on a train
just kind of like chillin', hanging out,
is the one that's gotten
all this attention.
But I'm like, it is the
most authentic, like,
expression of myself, because I'm like,
I'm not taking the stroller on the train.
So what happened is a
friend of mine, Avery Young,
called me to be a part of this series,
the Floating Arts Museum.
And Avery, he's like
there's always performers
on the platforms in Chicago
but we wanna like push the boundaries,
take it a step further, and like bring
this musical experience to
people on the train car.
And I was like, "Sign me up, I love it."
And he says, so, "We're
gonna do this series
called 'Soul L.' We're
gonna bring the performance
right on the train."
And I said, "Well I'm
free that day, Avery,
but I'm not getting a
sitter, so I'm bringing
my little baby with me."
And instead of like putting him
in the stroller on the train,
I just put him in this MOBY Wrap,
and I said, "Come on Mason,
- You look so cool.
- Thanks.
- I'm like, I would have
tried to do the same thing
and it would've not been that,
- It would've been great.
It would've been great.
- But Mason, I sung with him
up until about 8 1/2 months
being pregnant with him
so he's used to like,
all of the music and everything.
- Didn't you find it hard,
though, there at the end?
Like your diaphragm just changes.
Like the end of pregnancy,
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Not you?
- No, no, no.
- Oh, yeah.
- I was like me either,
I've just read about it.
I nailed everything.
- No, at the end of my preganancy,
people wanted me to record something
and I was like, ugh, like
I couldn't get breath.
It was horrible.
- It was pretty awful.
- I know, I know.
Well, what's the goal
behind these performances?
- So the Floating Arts Museum
wants to connect people
through arts, culture, and music.
Just to do different programming
to push those boundaries
and to bring people together.
- Yeah.
- Which I was so grateful for
because that's the only thing
I ever want to use my
voice for is to regardless
of class, race, gender, you know,
- That's the thing about music.
- to just bring
- It brings everybody together.
- It just is a language that, you know,
that connects people.
And, so for that to happen in that space
was just, you know, a dream.
And it doesn't get more Chicago than like
deep house music on
the train in, you know,
- I think that's cool.
I think that's gonna become
like a tourist attraction.
- You know I think,
- People are gonna go,
"Wait have you done this?"
'cause I'd go.
You were on Season 13,
right, with Jennifer Lopez?
She was a judge?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And I do have to say she's
shockingly beautiful in person.
- It's annoying.
- Almost hard to look